Here's a neat little party trick, you can
do with 4 matches, that will impress your
friends, or scam them out of some money.
For this party trick you're gonna need
4 wooden matches, and a friend with a little
pocket change. (Rhys has $20 bill)
Start with the money on the table, and get
your matches ready. If you're using something
like these "strike on box matches", they should have a little cardboard retainer inside.
Set that on the table in front of you, and push one of the matches, into the hole on the end,
so that it stands up on its own. If you don't
have a cardboard strip, that's ok. Try using
the cover of the box instead. Now place the
money in front of the match, so that it butts
right up next to the bottom, then get two
more matches ready. These ones, will need
to be placed, so that the bottoms of the sticks
stand on top of the money, while the match
heads rest together at the top, forming a
very loose pyramid. Now challenge one of your
friends to remove the bill, without knocking
any of the matches over. Even the slightest
movement will make them fall, and your friends
should soon realize they can't do it, and
some might even think it's impossible. To
win the challenge, simply light the fourth
match, and hold the flame underneath the front
two, about half way down. When they both light
off, you can simply stand back, and wait for
the magic. As the flames travel down the match
sticks, you'll notice they slowly begin to
move, then suddenly levitate upward. When
both matches have lifted off, gently blow
out the flame to freeze them in place, and
simply reach in and remove the cash. You're
the winner of the trick, and if you decide
to give their money back, they'll probably
be twice as impressed. Well there's a little
party trick that will entertain your friends,
and could make you a little money doing it.
This video was brought to you by Audible.com,
and right now they're offering everyone a
free download. They have over 150,000 audiobooks
to choose from, including my personal favorite,
"The Richest Man in Babylon". This is the
book that taught me that there are rules to
having money, and that if you're willing to
learn the rules, you can have the money.
Whichever book you choose, it's yours to keep,
along with a 30 day free trial. To download
your free audiobook, go to www.audible.com/thekingofrandom,
or click the link in the description.
Well that's it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com